[MUSIC]
So, now we will discuss how to
implement sequence alignment in a more
efficient way.
Usually, we compare quite long sequences
up to
few tens of thousands of amino acids And
runtime of alignment algorithms, as you
know, is
proportional to the number of edges, which
is quadratic.
And memory consumption,
consumption of alignment algorithm is also
proportional to
the number of nodes, which is also
quadratic.
And memory is a, often bottleneck.
Because on run time you can execute
billions of configurations in one second,
but to store billions of values in memory
you need one or few gigabytes of memory.
And, if you want to compare longer and
longer,
longer sequences, you still can wait for
many seconds.
When we, while your algorithms try to
compute this alignment, but
you don't have such huge amount of memory,
which is needed, for algorithms.
So how can we do this?
Let's define middle column of our
Manhattan grid as a column in the middle,
and so it's quite simple.
And we define middle node in Manhattan
grid.
It's a node where an optimal alignment
path crosses the middle column.
For example, in this grid, we have a, a,
this highlighted node, it's a middle node.
Because our optimal parts go through this
node,
and in this node is in the middle column.
Let's design algorithm to find sequence
alignment.
We, first step, we need to find a middle
node.
Then, we need to find alignment between
the source and middle node.
And after that, we need to find alignment
between middle node and the sink,
since we know all parts of a path, we can
do it recursively.
So the only
problem is how to find this middle node,
because we don't know yet.
Let's first discuss how to find alignment
score in linear space.
Previously, we used backtracking pointers
to find
the longest path, and it required
quadratic memory.
But what if we don't need this longest
path,
but we want to know only the score of
alignment?
Can we skip
storing these backtracking pointers, and
use less memory?
Just to find alignment score without
alignment itself.
Let's take a look on our Manhattan grid
and
we have a first column and we know
Aurelius
in the first column, after that, we can
compute
all scores in the second column using the
first column
variables only.
And that's the same as we
previously discussed when describing
alignment algorithm.
But for third column, we don't need to
know values
of the first column, and we can simply
forget them.
And reuse this memory.
Because for a third column, we can use
only scores from the second column,
and so on and so on and so on.
And at each moment of
this algorithms, we need to store only two
columns.
And we don't need to store all scores of
all nodes in our Manhattan grid.
And now we know how to find alignment
score in linear
space, but we want to find all alignment
in linear time.
So let's go back to
our middle column and middle node.
So, middle column was a column in the
middle and middle node was a node where
optimal paths crosses this middle column.
Let's define i-paths.
It's a longest path among all paths that
visit i-th node in the middle column and
for example, lengths of zero paths
is two here, and lengths of four paths is
four.
And, let's try to compute these numbers.
Lengths of all i-paths in the middle
column.
For example here, in this graph, it's two,
three, three, four, three, and one.
And four, our middle node, is a maximum
node in this
vector of lengths of i-paths.
So, lengths of i-paths.
We should be able to write down this
length of
i, is consists of from, fromSource i and
toSink i.
Which is two parts of our path from source
to
this node, and from this nord, node to the
sink.
And we can find all values
from source i just by going through the
first part of
Manhattan grid, using our linear space
algorithm
to calculate alignments course results
alignments
itself.
And we also can find a vector of
failures from sink by going in the second
part
of Manhattan grid, but by course.
So, we'll start at our sink, and it'll
go by backward edges, trying to reach this
middle column, also in linear space.
So we will know alignments course, but we
won't know alignments which
led to this course.
And after we have this two
vectors, from source and to sink, we can
sum
them up and find values in a middle
column.
So how many, what is the run time of this
algorithm So to find
from source, we need to visit area divided
by two of our whole Manhattan grid.
And to find toSink
vector of values, we need to also visit
area divided by two.
So we actually need to visit whole
Manhattan grid.
To find values in a middle node.
So isn't it too large?
Using the same run time as before, we
found only middle node.
So we found only single node, which
belongs to
our optimal path, and it required
quadratic time.
So, what can we do next?
We can split our Manhattan grid into four
parts and highlighted parts
here should be visited after you've found
middle node, because our
optimal path stay somewhere in these
areas.
But we can
skip other two areas from our
considerations on the next steps of
algorithms.
So on each of this highlighted part, we
need to
find, we don't know, how many time we will
take.
The area of this node is proportional to
the half of our area of whole Manhattan
grid so, we need only half of the time
which were required to find
single middle node to, find two more
middle nodes in this separated areas.
So, after this step you will have three
nodes which belongs to our
optimal alignment paths and we can iterate
more and more, so, on the next
step we will split our area into smaller
rectangles
and we will find middle node in each
rectangle, and so on and so forth.
And on the third level of recursion, the
total area which
we need, to take a look on, is
proportional to the
area divided by four.
And on
the fourth step, it's even smaller and
smaller.
And
during the whole algorithm.
Firstly, we visit, we visit that whole
area to find single node.
Single middle node.
And the next step, we visit that area
divided by
two to find more nodes in our optimal
alignment path.
And on the next step we see that area
divided by four, and so on and so on.
And this progression sum up to two
times area.
So it's actually linear that, linear
run time of this algorithms.
Linear by area of our Manhattan grid.
You can see the illustration here, for
example, for a first
pass we need to take a look on that one
area.
On the second pass we need to take a look
on that half of area.
And, on the third pass.
It's fourth, and so on and so on.
And you can easy take a look here that it
summed up to two.
So what have we done?
We designed algorithm which required
only linear space.
Because every step
in this recursion requires linear space to
find a middle node in a
given area.
And runtime of this algorithms is still
linear to the, our, our number of nodes
and
number of edges in alignment graph.
And by using this technique.
Its a little bit slower but by using this
technique, we can slow down
a little bit of run time but still find
whole alignment in linear space.